MALE SPEAKER: Hey, Jarek.
What's happening?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
I'm coding this--
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, that's great.
Say listen, I've been
talking to folks upstairs,
and we think we need to make
our apps a little more freemium.
Do you think you
can do that for us?
Maybe add a little
freemiumification to our apps?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Do you even
know what freemium means?
MALE SPEAKER: Jarek, look.
I'm more of what you might
want to call a big picture
kind of guy.
I don't like to get
bogged down in details
like, what is freemium, and
what does that even mean.
I like to leave that
people like you.
So what do you say?
Can you get this done for me?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Well, we could
reshuffle the schedule and--
MALE SPEAKER: That's great.
Hey, listen.
I kind of told the folks
in upper management
we'd have something
for them on Mondays.
So I'm going to have to ask
you to come in over the weekend
and get this done for me, OK?
Thanks a lot, Jarek.
You're a team player.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: It's Jarek.
MALE SPEAKER: Keep
up the good work.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hi,
I'm Jarek Wilkiewicz.
In this series,
I'm covering things
every developer
needs to understand
to be successful-- user
acquisition, engagement,
and earning money.
In this video, we'll focus on
the money part and freemium.
Freemium is a product
pricing strategy
where, instead of charging
the user for app download,
you make money on
in-app purchases,
or even up sell the
user to a subscription.
In-app purchases
and subscriptions
have already proven very
lucrative for games.
And according to
App Annie, they're
growing fast for
non-games as well.
To illustrate how this works,
let's look at a small example
called Trivial Drive, which
you can clone from GitHub.
The sample app is a
driving simulator,
except that you can't
actually do the driving.
But anyway, Trivial Drive
implements three types
of in-app purchases.
You can buy more gas,
upgrade your car,
and subscribe to the
unlimited gas service.
After your first
free tank of gas,
you have to purchase more by
hitting the Buy Gas button.
A nice dialogue pops up
which guides the user
through a frictionless
purchase flow.
The gas is what's called
a consumable item.
The car consumes the fuel, and
the user needs to buy more.
You can upgrade the car
to a fancier red one.
This is an example of purchasing
a non-consumable item.
The car upgrade is
a one-time purchase.
Let's now look at how
that's implemented.
Before you can sell something,
you need to have inventory.
The in-app digital products
offered by your app
are configured in the Google
Play Developer Console.
As you can see, I have
set up gas as a Stock
Keeping Unit, or a
SKU, with a price of $1
and the ID of a value of gas.
The ID is what the mobile app
uses to look up the product
and initiate the purchase flow.
To initiate gas
purchase, Trivial Drive
constructs a byte pendingIntent,
starts it, and then
processes the response in the
handle activity result method.
As you can see, Google Play
handles the purchasing flow.
At this point, the user is in
the possession of extra gas,
so the app updates the
fuel gauge display.
Because gas is a consumable
product, following
the successful
gas purchase flow,
Trivial Drive also calls
the consumePurchase method.
ConsumePurchase tells
the Google Play back end
that the user took
inventory of the product.
The call to consume
purchase is necessary
because the Google
Play back end does not
make a distinction
between a consumable item,
such as gas, or a
non-consumable item,
for example, an
item representing
an upgrade to a fancy red car.
While Google Play
tracks the purchases,
so you don't have to,
managing the user's inventory
is your job.
All right.
So far I've showed you how
to handle in-app product
purchases-- for example, getting
more gas, or a premium car
upgrade.
Now let's talk
about subscriptions.
Let's suppose I want my
car to go on forever,
without having to
worry about fuel.
For a small fee,
Trivial Drive lets
me purchase recurring
subscription
so that my tank is always full.
To implement
subscriptions, you need
to first configure a new product
in the Google Play Developer
Console.
Configure the name and the
ID, the price, billing period,
and even offer a free trial.
Then, in the app, you
kick off the purchase flow
like in the gas example.
This time, the SKU
ID is infinite gas.
Trivial Drive constructs
a byte pendingIntent,
starts it, and then
processes the response
in the handle activity
result method.
And voila, we done
with subscriptions.
Finally, I wanted to cover
one more aspect of using
the in-app billing API.
What if the app is restarted,
or uninstalled, and installed
again?
Or what happens if the phone
runs out of battery right
after the user
completes the purchase?
The Google Play in-app billing
API keeps track of purchases
so you don't have to.
Your app can retrieve products
owned by the user at any time.
It is a good practice
to always do that
upon application start-up.
This way, you don't have to
maintain purchases in the app.
And since the API utilizes
a persistent cache,
the response time is good.
Restoring purchases
upon start-up
also conveniently
handles the corner case
when the app crashes right after
the user completes a purchase.
There's a lot more
to the purchase flow
that we did not
cover-- for example,
handling refunds and managing
your digital products
programmatically using the
Google Play Developer API.
What's even more important
is securing transactions.
You can use several techniques
enabled by the Google Play
in-app billing API
to prevent bad actors
from spoofing in-app purchases.
Check out this Google I/O
talk by Bruno Oliveira.
To learn more about Google
Play in-app billing API,
visit our documentation, or
better yet, run the sample
Trivial Drive application, which
comes with several convenience
classes you can reuse
in your own app.
Note that you need to publish
the app to the alpha channel
before you can try it out.
Last, but not least, remember
that the Google Play in-app
billing API is designed
for digital products only.
If you would like to sell
physical products in your app,
check out our Android Pay API.
On behalf of your boss and
the in-app billing API,
I would like to say,
thank you for watching.